hi I'm Katie I lead the data team at
gloss genius which for those of you who
are not familiar with gloss genius is an
all-in-one app for people who run booty
salons as independent owner operators
just booking payments helps them build
their business very helpful in the year
of 2023
and I also had a extensive intro but um
I leave the business analytics team at
gloss genius it's a privilege to be with
you all here today to tell the founding
story of The Business Review program at
our company
now I know this topic sounds boring
um probably done these meetings candidly
can be very boring but ours in fact has
been described by meeting participants
is spicy
as well as quote highly productive I
personally have described at least one
meeting as excruciating in a
conversation with our CFO but
nonetheless these meetings are a forum
for data on one of the biggest stages in
a business context and they tie back to
the work that most people any data role
do albeit to different degrees of
separation
foreign
ours is also up leveled the quality of
discussion our data at the company on
the whole and influence our key decision
makers in very meaningful ways before I
jump in any further
sorry is my microphone working okay
cool
I can also yell
um quick quick high level agenda of what
we're going to cover today so we're
going to start from the beginning talk
about the impetus for the meeting launch
as well as the motivations for the
various parties involved in it
um break it break down the steps we took
leading up to launch as well as the
thought process behind them and our
choice of approach
talk about how it actually went the good
the bad the unexpected and the things
that we learned from the meetings
inaugural chapter
where how it's evolved since Inception
where we want to take it next and
finally we'll wrap up with some high
level takeaways from our experience on
the whole
so a business review meeting is
something that maybe sounds like a lot
of work and it definitely is and maybe
it's not the most exciting work but
we're going to talk a little bit about
why this is something that you should
care about uh and why we are excited to
have this as a part of our team's
portfolio a gloss genius uh and point
number one the iceberg metaphor is
perhaps a bit overtaxed in the analytics
space but I think it's an apt one for
helping people understand what data
teams do and really where data comes
from it is shocking to me how many
people have no idea where data comes
from before they see it in a dashboard
or in a slide deck or in a dock a
business review meeting is a really good
place for the data team to start
explaining what goes into the work that
you do a lot of times people only see
what an analyst does but it's a great
opportunity to highlight and give credit
to analytics engineers and data
Engineers who maybe don't get the
Limelight or the exposure and just
generally build an understanding for
people at the company of what the team
does how it works and why it's important
another very valuable thing about a
business review meeting is you get
undivided exact same attention uh
Robert's talk earlier in this track
actually talked about how one of the
best ways to be impactful as an analyst
is to report into your c-suite and
sometimes you can't you can't do that uh
it's already done and decided and if you
can't a business review meeting is the
next best thing it's time that you can
spend showing the executive team what
your team does helping them understand
what's important about the business as
told through metrics and it gives you a
way to counteract things that are
perhaps more available or or more
exciting or pleasing like a glowing post
on social media it's it's something that
allows you to balance that with
something that's perhaps a bit more
objective and I would say analytics is
is fun and great to talk about but maybe
it feels a bit more like taking their
vitamins to them this is the way that
you can force them to do it
and then finally another very important
motivation for doing a business review
meeting is that this is kind of like a
product surface we talk a lot about
product thinking in data these days we
talk about data products and a business
review meeting is something that you
should think of in that way as well it's
something that you should have a
specific purpose for you should have a
specific target audience in mind and
it's something that does not have to be
perfect when you first roll it out that
is probably the part of it that is
scariest for a lot of analysts and
analytics professionals is we want
things to be perfect we want things to
be right but sometimes momentum and
practice and iteration is how you get to
the best outcome and using a business
review meeting as an opportunity to
practice your product thinking and to
evolve and adapt what you are doing
based on regular recurring Face Time and
feedback with your executive team is
super valuable
but where do you start
so business reviews are new they're
they're actually fairly ubiquitous
Amazons is probably the most famous
within the data World
famously has hundreds of charts and
tables presented as slide decks a team
of 80 plus people working on it but
while there's a lot of discourse about
the ideal end state
um there's there's far less in the way
of sort of how you actually get to that
point uh particularly in a startup
setting with a small Scrappy data team
who is strapped for time and resources
so we're here to offer an anecdote
the origin of our business trivia
meeting was probably October last year I
had been at gloss genius for about two
months and my boss came to me and said
Katie we need a business review meeting
and it needs to be weekly my initial
reaction was weekly seems like a lot
these are a ton of work I don't know if
we can do that and he was like no it
needs to be weekly I was like okay well
can we start doing it in q1 there's a
lot of other stuff we need to do first
to prepare and make sure that this is
actually good and he's like no we need
to do it now so I had to sit down and
think about how we would actually do
this in a scalable fashion especially if
we had to do it on a weekly Cadence and
I came up with an initial recipe
there were kind of three main things
that I thought were very important for
us to pin down before we did this one
was the goal a business review meeting
seems like it should be like oh you're
reviewing the business but what does
that actually mean and what does it
actually look like that was something I
wanted to clarify
since it's about metrics you need to
have metrics about which ones you pick
is pretty important as well and then
finally a pretty strong belief I had
going in was that this document or this
meeting needed to be based around a
document rather than a slide deck or
something else a document is a format
that is perhaps more familiar to an
executive who is used to reading and
commenting and emailing and that sort of
thing rather than waiting into your data
tools and it's better than a slide deck
because it allows four comments to exist
in line and be a bit more interactive we
also wanted there to be something that
came before the meeting so people would
come in prepared ideally although that
didn't always happen in practice
in terms of setting our expectations on
the goal I wrote out an actual document
in the spirit of
promoting documents where I talked about
what I expected from everyone involved
the first thing was an expected time
commitment I wanted people to be very
clear on the fact that they were going
to do this once a week for an hour which
is a lot and also it's more than that
because I expected them to read this
document in advance
I wanted to be very clear about who
would be in this meeting
this is sort of an opportunity for these
people to build relationships build a
circle of trust and know the altitude of
discussion that they would be having so
they should all know that going in
I wanted the goal to be discussion
specifically it's very easy for this to
seem like the data team is going to come
and tell you what to think about the
company or about the metrics and having
it be discussion focused was something
that we really really pushed and
continued to push
and then finally we highlighted our
expected outcomes and as a stylistic
flourish tied them to some of our
company values to get in good graces of
the CEO learning fast was a really
important one people needed to become
familiar with the data there's a lot of
profession to be data driven and data
literate but this is a great way to
really make sure that people are doing
that regularly
we wanted people to be more successful
the data team has a very high level view
of everything that's going on in the
business but we don't necessarily have
deep context for what everyone else is
up to nor do Executives have deep
context and view into other departments
so this is a great way for people to
share what's happening in their corner
of the company with everyone else
and then finally owning the outcome this
is about accountability we really wanted
goals to be a focus of the meeting and
to talk about them regularly so if
something was off track we would know
right away and be able to do something
about it and this is a spoiler but the
company's more successful because of
that because we have been able to
identify things like this early because
of this meeting
in terms of the metrics uh we're a newer
data team you could generously say we've
existed for maybe like eight months so
we didn't have a lot of prefab metrics
written up and in the interest of doing
this meeting quickly and doing it weekly
we decided to start with metrics that we
already had
knowing that they were not the right set
of metrics and that we would change them
over time
we started essentially with our investor
metrics the document itself is kind of a
Frankenstein of a bunch of looker
screenshots uh and and Google Sheets
charts that we've used to give people
something concrete to react to and
compiled all into one place and that is
how we began
and then finally the pre-read document
we gave people sort of a sample of what
it would look like
this is kind of similar to what it looks
like today but the essential ingredients
here were it was very clear who is
responsible for explaining why the Metro
was doing things
having a Time series chart so people
could actually see Trends rather than
just see a number knowing how things
change over time it's easier said than
done you really need to see the
visualization to get a good sense of
what it looks like
goals and quantitative context on them
so each metric was intended to have its
actual value today the goal metric and
progress towards it and finally we
wanted qualitative context on the
metrics there are things that are not
immediately obvious from a goal versus
actual or a Time series chart might be
something that happened in the company
like a new marketing launch or something
like that that we wanted to be clear so
there was a bit more context on a root
cause for a metrics movement
so with all the planning and thought
that went in to this meeting our debut
must have gone
very smoothly
right
not at all
um
we we went into it knowing this uh so
did our executive sponsor
um I personally was was a bit nervous
going in
um intentionally putting forward a
crappy looking product to our executive
team who
um disproportionately comes from a
finance background or whether or not to
put a period at the end of a bullet
point is something that warrants
discussion and debate
um but although we didn't stick our
Landing we we still made it to the
ground
so in terms of what in particular didn't
go as expected there's three things I
would highlight the first is no one
actually wanted to own metrics during
the meeting so as a result
we were sort of left having to fill in
all the commentary for all the metrics
and Trends happening across the business
and people actually came to the meeting
expecting to be told why metrics were
moving as opposed to being prepared to
discuss potential root causes as a group
uh the second is that it became very
clear that everyone in the group was
accustomed to looking at metrics and the
way that we were the new way we were
presenting them so the screenshot here
at the bottom right of the slide is a
weekly or daily email that has gone out
to our leadership team since before
Katie and I's time it's a snapshot of
metrics from our operational database
and it's essentially people were looking
used to looking at metrics in summary
form there's been dashboards that have
come and gone
um in the meantime but in this meeting
people were very eager to click in to
looker charts and try and get an
understanding of how metrics change over
time people really didn't have an
intuitive understanding power metrics
moved
people some people actually also called
voice confusion around the specific ways
we were calculating metrics and called
into question the quality or the
correctness of the data itself
it was uncomfortable to say the least
and the third is people actually saw
this meeting as a work intake forum for
the data team so we spent quite a bit of
effort actually deflecting in meeting
requests that people were making on the
Fly and also using it as an opportunity
to
sort of communicate as well as reinforce
the realistic turnaround times for data
work which to No Surprise
um takes longer than most outside of a
data team expected to
running this meeting was really
exhausting the first couple of times
that we did it we we left it drained and
very uncertain as to whether like anyone
found it valuable and we were pretty
diligent about asking for feedback
regularly from the subset of the
executive team that we were working on
on putting the meeting together
and pretty soon after we started doing
it one of the times that I sought
feedback we were told that the meeting
was working people were asking better
questions and becoming more familiar
with the data and we got the High Praise
that the group was tolerating us
I always strive to be tolerated so I was
very reassured by this
um and really then the the impetus for
us was to figure out how we evolved this
meeting fast enough that they would
continue to tolerate it and the
production schedule was very aggressive
for this this is a weekly meeting a
typical week means we assemble this
document on Monday when the previous
week's data is all complete and the
metrics are calculated Tuesday we sent
it out for a pre-read one's daily
discuss and then we have Tuesday and
Thursday or Thursday and Friday to react
to it
this meant that we had a very hectic
life and continue to have a little bit
of a hectic life around this I actually
assembled this document on the plane on
Monday today or this week
um and in general it felt like we were
laying the tracks of the train right
before we ran over them
um and we had to try a lot of different
things over the past couple of months to
make this meeting better
for example
common complaint that we got early on
was when a metric moved people didn't
know if it was important or not one
thing that we tried to do as a custom
visualization this one in particular the
dotted lines are more or less a
confidence interval and anything outside
of the trend line or outside of the
dotted lines was considered truly
anomalous this did not work actually
mostly ended up making conversation even
less productive where we were digging
into root cause analysis that we just
couldn't really explain because we
weren't subject matter experts and
generating these charts was also a lot
of work a lot of wrangling with
matplotlib definitely not worth the
effort so I ended up deprecating them
very quickly after we tried building
them
another thing that we tried to do to get
better root cause analysis was bring in
special guests some of these people
provided more or worked better in the
flow of the meeting than others one
thing that happened that we thought was
interesting but not necessarily where we
wanted to go uh was we had presentations
this started feeling a bit like a show
and tell and distracted from the goal of
the meeting which was discussion so we
kind of banished presentations as much
as possible and the most effective way
that we found to bring people in was to
have them help write commentary on the
metrics that we saw I'm one of the
people who helped us do this became such
a valuable member of the meeting that he
is now a permanent member of it and
continues to add a lot of value
another thing that we noticed pretty
quickly as we started to get more
comfortable with the metrics is that we
felt smarter for having discussed them
but didn't really do anything about it
one thing that we tried to do about this
was synthesize action items from the
meeting by taking notes during the
meeting and then sending out an email
afterwards we tried bringing in an AI
note taker at one point because we had a
in-person hybrid meeting the transcript
was actually totally unreadable because
everything was attributed to one voice
for the person who had their mic on but
also like the administrative burden of
this meeting doing this every single
week running the meeting preparing the
meeting preparing the document having to
go and read a transcript and pull out
action items afterwards was just not
scalable for us and the way that we
ended up actually using action items was
we reserved about the last five minutes
of the meeting to talk about okay what
does this discussion mean and what are
we going to do about it and then posting
it in slack so that we could Knack
people throughout the week to remember
that they had actually signed up for an
action item
so where does that leave us today
the meeting is working
it uh it's still based around a
pre-re-document
um albeit more contribution comes from
more people
um goals are broken out into our own
separate section the actual format and
look of the document itself is evolved a
bit as you can see here the before on
the left and the present day on the
right
and discussions are actually
intentionally focused in the meeting on
topics that people disagree with
those make for Fruitful conversations
that lead to actionable impactful
outputs so in short
keep the spice levels up
but there's still quite a bit of room to
improve so
where we want to take it next there's
three things that are top of mind
the first being is we need to go further
to establish better in meeting role
Clarity so we have a a large attendee
list spanning multiple departments
multiple job levels and everyone comes
to the meeting with a different set of
motivations and incentives
we also have a wide array of
personalities in the room from the Brash
and loud to the more reticent and
reserved often those folks have the best
context on the metrics we're looking at
so sort of creating a way to allow more
people to have their voices heard and
ultimately keep us we're focused we see
that we see establishing better Clarity
on roles as a means of doing that
the second is we have a lot of breadth
at the moment we are still lacking in
depth and that depth really needs to
come from people who are closest to each
of the metrics and what's happening
across the business on a day-to-day
basis
and the third is just figuring out a
more scalable and sustainable way to
actually support a weekly Cadence we
can't sort of have two to three business
days to turn this around and produce new
information and content at the pace that
the business wants us to so figure out a
different structure that allows us to
sort of distribute that administrative
burden across more folks
the structure that we're going to be
moving forward with is something that we
are calling rotating spotlights and the
key idea of this is that we have
multiple important departments at the
company and once a month they're going
to be on stage and have to talk about
what's going on there
what we hope this is going to do is one
put more people in the driver's seat uh
right now because of the personalities
involved there are certain subjects that
are just always the topic of the meeting
it's just kind of always about that
that's always the thing that people have
follow-up questions about and by
balancing uh the topics that we speak
about we're going to force people who
maybe are quiet but have good domain
context on an area of the company that
people don't regularly think about
they're naturally going to have to share
what they know a lot more and the people
who maybe would be more talkative more
more enforcing of their perspective are
going to have to listen more which is
something that we think is very valuable
also having those people come on stage
and our proverbial stage I suppose
it's going to force their subject matter
expertise into the Limelight a lot more
this is also something that is allowing
us to pull in analysts who are working
specifically in those areas to to
provide more detail and more oversight
and more context and help them build
their relationship with their
stakeholders the way this is working is
analysts essentially are selecting the
metrics and picking the initial set of
what we talk about with oversight and
commentary coming from Department leads
and Executives of different parts of the
company to help us all learn more about
what's going on in detail from people
who are involved in the actual things
happening
and finally if someone only has to talk
once a month they have a lot more
incentive to go into detail these people
can think about what they need to say
how the last one went and actually plan
for four weeks instead of two days what
they talk about in the meeting
if you want to build your own business
review program at your company and I
encourage you to it's something that has
been extremely impactful for us the
understanding of data and the data team
at our company is so much better for it
watching metrics move together has
helped our executive team understand the
levers that drive the business so much
better and as in impacting our company
strategy as well as helping us recognize
when a goal is lagging and we can act
faster that's something you can do too a
business review meeting does not have to
be super complicated to do and we're
going to talk to you about some advice
if you want to do that yourself
one think through your recipe the recipe
I used is going to work really well I
think if you if you do it right pick a
goal for your meeting make sure the
participants know what the goal of this
meeting is when they participate so they
can participate constructively
start with metrics that you already have
this will have an added bonus of people
already being familiar with them so they
won't necessarily like have to think
about like oh what does that actually
even mean it's less work for you there's
more of a chance that they will
understand the metric well at the get go
and you can always change the metrics
that you talk about later
and finally have some kind of consistent
structure for this meeting I really like
pre-read documents maybe you don't but
whatever you do have a consistent
structure the structure means that
people will focus more on the content
and it allows you to get to the
important discussion and
misalignment resolution and everything
that you need to do in this meeting by
having it be the same every single time
and general advice that you can take
with you one the best way to ensure that
people are familiar with metrics is to
make them look at them regularly as much
as everyone professes to be data driven
a lot of people actually don't use
metrics to think about what's happening
a meeting like a metrics meeting is
essentially an exercise in group data
analysis and it forces people to learn
how to think with data
two production value and fancy methods
are so much less important than
consistency whenever we tried to do a
complicated or statistical chart we're
really trying to shortcut people
building intuition and familiarity with
the data and it was way easier to just
get people to look at the document every
week and build intuition over time
and finally
these meetings do not need to be perfect
it can feel uncomfortable to show
something that feels unfinished to your
stakeholders
but it's so much better to get feedback
early because you know if you're on the
the right or wrong track so much sooner
and you can evolve it with them together
uh and build a better product as a
result
foreign